Florida Governor Rick Scott joins us now
from the South Florida Water Management
Center in West Palm Beach
governor good morning good morning tell
us I want everybody just listen to the
evacuation orders Charlie they we have
got to we everybody to think about your
family I love my family
I want my Senate family be safe I want
to protect them I think about that with
this state so if there is evacuation
orders in your area you've got to listen
to him what is the latest that you can
tell us about the expectation of when
the storm hits and the devastation from
it well here's what's different between
this and Andrew this is bigger than
Andrew and we're going to have way more
storm surge so we're gonna start seeing
hurricane force winds tonight in the
keys and it just looks like if you look
if they follow the track it's gonna come
up right in the middle of state which is
slight move could decide it's gonna go
to the west coast versus the East Coast
that's why I've said all along every
don't be complacent we not sure exactly
where this is gonna go listen to the
evacuation orders think about your life
think about your family's life but five
to ten feet of storm surge in the
southern part of the state thinking
about that that's gonna cover homes
we're not a high state we don't have
mountains in this state so you've got to
think about if you're close to the coast
the storm surge can be devastating we
didn't have that in Andrew it's totally
different than Andrew we're gonna have
horrible winds but but it's gonna be the
storm surge that really worries me
governor we're reporting and I know
you're concerned about this as well that
you've got gas stations in Miami Fort
Lauderdale 4050 percent of them already
closed are people gonna have the
resources to get out we've worked hard
to try to get as much fuel in the state
as possible I've provided escorts to the
tankers they're taking it from the fuel
depot to the gas stations we're asking
this the gas station stay open as long
as possible we'll help you will provide
you please escort out to evacuate we've
talked to the White House EPA we've
gotten regulations waived so we get more
fuel in here also you know airports are
eventually you know Everglades it's
going to close soon so we're we're
working hard Thank You governor Scott